what is the significance of singing in
humans why do we have two distinct
registers why can we do this and then
there's a link which we didn't have time
to look at so I'm not sure what exactly
the question is asking and why is it so
emotionally stimulating love from
Scotland
[Music]
so I actually I'm not sure exactly what
the two distinct registers oh I know
he's referring to either male and female
are an octave apart is that but that but
but we but you know we obviously have
overlapping ranges oh it's it's it's a
rare man we're we're woman who have no
overlapping ranges right we sing we have
overlapping ranges but there's nothing
else around two distinct registers I
thought it might be like a friar like I
don't think so I mean I'd take it to be
male and female so let's put it this way
you've asked a very deep question which
would require a book to answer but let
me simplify it a little bit
one the distinction between singing and
music is a new one so it would have been
true until very recently until the
invention of musical instruments that
music was inherently vocal and in
general contained lyrics it was
inherently lyrical almost all the time
it would also be true that all that
basically every intact human would have
a direct relationship with music they
wouldn't just consume it they would
participate in the creation of it and
music wasn't static it used to be that
even the songs that your tribe sung were
songs that changed over time right so
even the standards we're never the same
twice and then at some point the
invention of the player piano songs
start to be the same twice and then that
gets really bad in the era of recorded
music oh but it's far before that at the
point that music is being written down
the Baroque era there's that you have
repeated music oh you have repetition
you've always had that but the idea of
exact repetition I think I think that at
the point that the Baroque era was upon
us or maybe even earlier and I'd known
far less about what came before the
Baroque but you know we we know what
could
been and was being played over and over
and over again from boy Bach would have
been 1600s I think so
you know repetition has been going on
for as well as long as the written word
do you think music has been Burrup far
longer than I think it has but you set
yourself up but so let's put it this way
there is something to be said about the
player piano being the first point at
which the song might be the same twice
but I agree with you you know written
music does invite the attempt to produce
the same song twice and a conductor
might do the same rendition twice so
anyway they'd be very close but this is
all of it it's a departure from the
natural state of music which would
almost always have been lyrical and
would always have been vocal until I
don't know the invention of the first
musical instruments so the point is the
answer to the question is really going
to be found in what is the evolutionary
advantage of vocal music right and I'm
gonna leave you hanging there but I
would say one of the things you need to
recognize it order to address this
puzzle is the close connection that
music has to the production of language
and anyway I have a long-standing
hypothesis here which needs to be
explored at some point yeah we should we
should devote an hour more to this at
some point but this one thing that just
occurred to me which had never really
occurred to me before is that I mean it
as as you know I was I was trained in
classical piano played for you know
practice for a couple hours a day for
many years during my childhood and so
the Baroque period sort of happened and
I don't know a lot about you know what
exactly happened before them but Baroque
was during in part the era of clavichord
harpsichord where there wasn't dynamic
possibility you didn't have the ability
as you did with the piano the pianoforte
which was the thing that that changed
about the keyboard was and now you could
play softly or loudly right and it was
very much
as I understand it you know the baroque
led to the Classical period and in both
of those both those cases yes the
musician who was playing the music could
change what was being played but you
really weren't supposed to stray and at
least for you know someone playing
individual piano music from the Baroque
you know like Bach and then the
Classical period you know Beethoven
Brahms Haydn etc we're very much
supposed to be played as they were
written whereas then you move into the
Romantic period in the 19th century like
Chopin and Tchaikovsky and such and you
suddenly get a lot more freedom again
you know sometimes they'd stuff so many
notes into a single measure that you
could just you know do kind of whatever
you want want it dynamically and
metrically and it was almost like a
return to what music was what music was
before before I feel like the sort of
the drum the you know the the metronome
ik enforcement of things from the
Baroque period happened and I don't know
I don't know what all that was about
like why that happened well I mean I
think you're on the right track in the
sense that the elaborateness of the
instruments and the you know though in
the case of the harpsichord in
particular the mechanistic nature of the
instruments invites a more mechanistic
playing style so you think the
technology may have driven the musical
style yeah none of which almost is is
about singing which is its own you know
it is the original instrument of course
yep and and amazing
[Music]